on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
I am Rosanna Lockwood here on uncensored
tonight Prince Harry is back on Netflix
with a new series which aims to put the
spotlight on his military and charitable
service but is it too late for the
servicemen who said he'd let them down
and does anybody really need more Harry
content
calls to ban or move Notting Hill
Carnival after eight stabbings 300
arrests and shocking footage that's been
seen around the world Defenders say
racism is amplifying all of it so they
have a point
plus and out of this world exclusive
I'll talk to the Harvard scientists
making Global headlines today after
claiming alien materials been recovered
from the bottom of the Pacific Ocean
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored with
Rosanna Lockwood well good evening from
London welcome to Piers morganland
center with me Rosanna Lockwood in the
chair for the penultimate night Piers
back next week now Recollections may
vary the late Queen famously said that
of Harry and Megan's sit-down interview
Oprah Winfrey Not For the First Time
those words are now being used to
suggest that Prince Harry could be
mistaking the truth for his truth and
not for the first time the criticism is
about a Netflix documentary Harry's new
five-part series heart of Invictus
premieres today and it tells the story
of six competitors in the Invictus games
the sporting contest he created for
wounded servicemen and women
in an interview for the show he says his
own military service brought back the
trauma of losing his mother he takes a
little swipe then at the royal family in
the process
the biggest struggle for me was the
people no one around me really could
help I didn't have that support
structure that Network or that expert
advice to identify what was actually
going on with me now critics did point
out that Harry has publicly thanked his
brother Prince William in the past for
urging him to get therapy back in 2017.
elsewhere in the show Harry again
criticizes the media this time he says
the Press was not interested in stories
about British troops wounded in
Afghanistan
three young British soldiers
all wrapped in plastic and their bodies
in pieces
I saw what only people had talked about
that was the real trigger for I'm now
seeing the real cost of War
stepping foot off the plane
I was angry that this has happened to
these guys I was angry that the media
weren't covering it our various
journalists from a wide range of
Publications are saying that's not true
they've got clips and cuttings to prove
it the new series is supposed to put the
spotlight back on Harry's military and
charitable service so tonight we're
asking whether it's all a bit too little
too late and just potentially another
act in what some call the seemingly
endless Sussex circus for more on this
joined by the journalist and broadcaster
Nina miskov and the commentator Lynn May
and the former commander in Afghanistan
Colonel Richard Kemp Colonel uh as
you're sitting there thank you for
making time for us this evening want to
get your initial reactions to this and
the way it will likely be received
amongst the military Community
especially those that went to
Afghanistan
you know I think I mean Prince Harry
enjoyed enormous popularity in the armed
forces both for his his determination to
serve in Afghanistan on two occasions
and also for the help he gave to wounded
soldiers partly through Invictus games
um unfortunately he's blown most of her
away now
um and a combination of his turning on
his own family the royal family which
means such a lot to the armed forces and
his attempts to exploit his own Service
uh for his own publicity purposes and we
we only need to think back about what he
said about how he killed so many Taliban
members uh a short while ago in his
Memoir spare
for me the greatest problem with that
Memoir I wasn't boasting about killing
Taliban terrorists of course that was
his job and and he's quite right to do
so but he did say and I think it was for
the benefit of his work friends in
California
that uh that he was conditioned by the
Army to treat them as sub-human as less
than human beings which is simply not
true but plays well to the woke agenda
so I think those things uh have have
combined have led him to be I wouldn't
say vilified exactly but certainly trade
with much greater suspicion and much
less affection in the armed forces than
he was before
okay so you really think he's gone down
a woke path let's come into the studio
for some Royal analysis Nina is this
what could get Harry back into the good
graces of the British people well I've
watched the first two episodes of the of
the series and it is fantastic it is
very compelling the stories are
wonderful it's beautifully filmed it's
very very emotional it's actually very
moving you actually I find it hard to
watch without crying at some of the
stories of these incredibly Brave
um Afflicted soldiers and and what the
games mean to mean to them but to but to
just to pick out those two little
phrases and
you would imagine that the whole thing
is about Harry whining on it's not at
all that it's the story of the games the
story of the people and the story of
what the games mean to them and those
two comments that you've picked up when
he said he didn't get therapy when he
when he he may have been advised to get
therapy but you you need to have more
than that I think what he was pointing
out was that there's the great
loneliness when you come back from
active service and all the all the um
the servicemen said that the loneless
you're on you're on your own and and you
know only when you're in a fetal
position lying on the ground crying that
you realize that you do need something
and he went he went for that and so
I don't see the I just don't see the
problem he's he's done a brilliant job
with Invictus games he continues to do
that and uh and I think this will go a
long way to showing you know it's very
unfair to pick out these tiny things
it's a five-part series and these are
two comments that less than 20 seconds
each Lin bringing you in for your
reaction uh funny enough I do Echo a lot
of what you say
um you know there's so many people that
have watched this and they've been
empowered but the only thing I would
agree with with some of the commentary
is that it is being slightly
disingenuous and I think it is almost
offensive to the services because
um
armies the Navy or they offer counseling
after and it would have been nice for
him to say maybe I didn't take the
support maybe I didn't reach out but
there was that support available to me
because as we know he did receive
therapy when he was 28 he did receive
the therapy after Diana his mother's
death so it's a bit frustrating to hear
how he's said it but like you said I
think that we're picking or the media's
picking on these tiny little things
where you know why don't we hear some of
the amazing things where he's donated
massive amounts from even his liberal
case he's donated from his Memoir he's
going to donate from this and we don't
seem to ever gravitate towards the
positives that he's doing it's always
these tiny little incidentals that we
hone in on and I think that's just
massively negative do you think you can
understand them why he creates these
Netflix series these six part series
it's his way of kind of countering that
narrative yeah and I think to be honest
I am one of those who was getting a bit
sick and tired of of Harry uh seeming to
be like a lost puppy behind Megan and
everything was all about you know what
they've gone through which is not always
a negative that's their truth however we
remember Harry for being this sort of
you know about the Invictus games about
his passion for those um servicemen and
what they went through and I think this
is actually going to win the hearts of
many uh instead of him just him and
Megan talking about much to do about
nothing this has real meaning so I'm
glad that he's done this let's bring
Colonel Richard Kemp back in then uh
listening into all of that
um very clear here in the studio people
think this is probably a good move in
terms of rehabilitating his image and
especially with regards to the Invictus
games which many consider to be quite a
Triumph
yeah and personally I have to say I'm
not interested in rehabilitating His
image I I really don't care what his
image is I think the important thing is
the wounded soldiers who take part in
the Invictus games that is the only
thing that's of any significance and I
you know I would really question what
what stress he was under during his
tenure of service in Afghanistan yes he
he insists that on going against
opposition to fight and to put himself
in danger but what was he doing he was
he was fighting a very very remote
distance not the kind of thing in my
view that would result in in serious
stress and PTSD compared to many of the
other soldiers who lost limbs had their
life shattered and in some cases
tragically were killed I think you know
I don't think we should be looking at
his image as being something of huge
importance to this except in as much as
he can bring publicity and and bring
public attention to these extremely
brave soldiers who gave so much and I
think that this documentary has that
benefits and his name being honest is
extremely important of course because it
brings publicity to their cause but only
if it results in I would say financial
and medical assistance to them not for
any other reason I don't I don't
personally buy all the the need to
rehabilitate His Image Etc I think you
know I think I think the key issue is
how much he can bring to the cause of
wounded soldiers who still suffer so
much today and still don't in many cases
receive the support they need it's just
an excellent point Colonel yes please I
think that's terribly unfair of of
Richard to say that that he couldn't see
what what could possibly stress Prince
Harry art is not for one human being to
say to another what can stress them out
anything can stress them out and I think
he he proved that he was Brave and he
proved in all sorts of areas that he
that he was willing to and and and ends
if you read spare and if you watch this
series you'll see that he
um he empathizes so much with his his um
his comrades he admires them he respects
them and the fact that he started up
Invictus games to to help them
and the interesting thing is the
interesting thing is when I I don't know
more about the Invictus games than
anybody else does and I just think well
it's it's people who are afflicted
physically but in fact the second part
of the series shows so much of the
mental and emotional trauma do not think
it's about it's become like the Harry
Fest disability I think
the pointing thing for me is this is
about six individuals who obviously had
uh struggles a hard time possibly lost
limbs we should be focusing on them we
shouldn't be looking at Harry yes he's
going to bring in publicity but we're
all here talking about Harry when the
conversation should not even be about
how because because the media picks on
Harry if you just watch the series he
knows that and he should have taken
himself away a little bit which should
have been about those individuals he's
hardly in it he present he's he's he
presents it and he pops up occasionally
just reinforcing or you see him in a
part of a meeting but it is the story of
these Heroes it's the story of these
individuals and that's what makes it so
compelling and so moving and the fact of
the matter is he has facilitated this he
has made this happen with about him this
would not have happened without him
there wouldn't be the games without him
there wouldn't be
um this series which I hope people will
watch because it is is a fantastically
inspirational it really is well let's
put that to Richard then could it be
possible that we'd have uh all the
publicity around the Invictus games and
everything that he's done uh with that
cause without having Harry feature is it
necessary to have him there to get
people interested in it
well I don't think it's necessary but I
think it is it's pretty important
you know you need in in in in today's
world you do need a kind of celebrity
figurehead and Harry in many ways is the
ideal one
um and so I think his role is important
in it but but I think as one of you
sorry I can't remember the names but as
one of your guests rightly pointed out
he should not be in my in my opinion he
should not be talking about his own
hardship because his own hardship is
almost irrelevant compared to the the
real sacrifices made by many of the
soldiers who are taking part in the game
he should be hosting and and presenting
them and their hardships and what you
know we we he I I have to say I disagree
with with one of your with you it was it
was Nina that put to you that um he
shouldn't be you know the idea that what
triggers people Harry said that at the
death of his mother that triggered him
when he was in Afghanistan the sort of
it all came back to him we can't say
what upsets people and what doesn't
shouldn't just be about a lot of
soldiers a lot of soldiers have lost
their mother or their father Etc it's
not it's not I mean okay it's a big
issue for the individual but but I don't
think that kind of feeds into the the
the the the the The Narrative of PTSD
which he's claiming to have I think you
know I think it's it's I I know that in
one individual can't read another
individual's mind but I I think his his
priorities should be very much on the on
the real sacrifices the tangible
sacrifices made by the other soldiers
that's exactly what he's doing that's
exactly what he's doing and making this
documentary that's exactly what he's
doing he's focusing on the stories of
these people we wouldn't have known
these stories of the documentary series
hadn't been made we wouldn't know it he
could have been involved without making
it about him though and that's not about
him if you watch the series it is not
about him it's only because the media
are picking on it it and he is perfectly
entitled to describe his own feelings as
a means of being showing empathy to the
people who have suffered in other ways
he can talk about his mental his mental
problems and and his and and and and all
the stress and Trauma that he has
perfectly rightly you know documented
then it means that people who are
struggling can feel I'm not alone and
people watching it will feel I'm not
alone if even he feels that or even you
know if this is how he's overcome it
then I can overcome it too I think
that's fantastically inspirational
well you may well be right there I I
wouldn't totally disagree with that but
but when we look at the mo one of the
most privileged people on the Earth
bringing his own story into it when he
in my opinion okay you know it's only
one of many opinions he should be
focusing not on his his travails and
hardships which are nothing really
compared to what many of the other
people have experienced he should be
focusing on highlighting what they've
done now great if this if this
documentary does actually achieve that
objective and and if it brings in money
and other forms of support to these
individuals then it's it's worthwhile
whatever we think of it I just want to
bring in Lynn as well because give her a
comment because when I'm listening to
this limb what I hear is potentially the
difference between civilian and Military
you're thinking about this very much
from an act of service uh Richard this
is what I'm reading I may not be reading
it right and then you're thinking it
very much of the sort of normal human
angle and people getting upset by
various things you're saying stiff upper
lip but I mean Lynn is that what you're
hearing no my my main takeaway from this
is yes I do agree that the media is
picking on Harry and we have a
responsibility to sometimes not hone in
on these incidentals that I've
previously said but at the same time
Harry is well aware what the media is
going to do and it's not as if we
haven't heard his experiences before I'm
not going to demean them he has every
right to express them but it would have
been nice if he veered away from talking
about himself and speaking about those
who have really gone through hardship
while being in service as the gentleman
said lost limbs and really suffered
during their time so that's the only
frustration for me it seems like you
know once again we're all concentrating
on Harry but I think yes it's a
two-pronged approach where the media are
to blame but Harry is well aware of what
the media is going to pick up but what
it actually said in the first two
episodes that I've watched it wouldn't
add up to 10 minutes you know so that
and then
Luke sorry leadership leadership is not
about telling other people how tough it
is for you it's not that that's not what
leadership is about leadership is about
understanding other people's hardships
and helps improve it it's exactly what
he's doing I'm not sure that it does
that by explaining how tough it is for
you I mean you know I've LED soldiers in
battle not for one moment would I
consider uh talking about the
difficulties I have and the problems I
have with them I think it's highlighting
their problems highlighting the help
that they need is the really important
part of this and and therefore I don't
really think what he's okay it may have
only been for a short part of it but I
don't think it should be any part of it
that he he kind of tries to evoke his
own sympathy I think there is while
while I hope this documentary does
uh create Sympathy for the and support
not just sympathy but support for the
Soldier's concern I don't think his you
know we we don't really need his own
promotion his own image in this and and
I've also you know I don't know how true
this is a lot but I understand that
Megan Merkel is going to give a talk to
the to these soldiers about overcoming
hardship and courage Etc now again I'm
not I don't know what she's going to say
I don't know why she's saying it but I
don't really think that's appropriate it
comes back down again to the to their
overwhelming needs I think to to
rehabilitate themselves after having it
can I just ask you Richard have you
actually watched the documentary I've
seen part of it I haven't seen the whole
thing though and also just one of the
correct obviously Meghan Markle Lynn I
could see your face there there um we do
have to wrap this up shortly Lynn do you
have any final comments based on what
Richard was just saying no I'll just say
you know there's there's good and bad to
take from this
um I'm happy that he's done this I'm
happy that it's mainly him and not Megan
there I know she makes an appearance but
I don't see the need for her to do that
um but yeah I do think that we have a
responsibility to not pick on these
small things when it's a massively
inspirational documentary but at the
same time just a little bit Fed Up of
Harry going on about his own experience
constantly all three of you thank you
very much for an in-depth conversation
there about this new documentary
thank you uncensored next tonight after
Harvard scientist claims he's recovered
alien material from the bottom of the
Pacific Ocean we bring you an out of
this world exclusive with him next
[Music]
good evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored
in New York City King peers and King Q I
think it's only one for one king
he's mocked your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail start working just because
their skin folk don't mean they're
kinfolks do you believe you can win this
war but he's making me cry again they're
trying to force you out yes I feel
betrayed keep it award-winning
Lucy Letty will die behind bars and a
senior Doctor Who first raised concerns
about that he wants NHS managers to be
regulated we needed answers a lot sooner
this is what seven years down the line I
mean it's completely ludicrous we need
accountability we need performance in
all walks of life if this nurse had
misgendered somebody on a board she'd
have been out the door when they first
got together there were press stories
weighty Katie that would make her a
better princess of wealth delay Maxwell
agreed to be interviewed for the very
first time I actually wish I'd never met
him Donald Trump has just said he
expects to be arrested at 7 30 P.M
the conservative party can certainly win
the next election can we yes
did you say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
[Music]
let it roll
if we stop producing oil the knock-on
effect is far larger than just CO2 I
nearly have empathy when I'm speaking to
them I know I know you're probably going
to vote me off
some of them they're easily LED
you can kiss my American Air thank you
very much very nice of you
Twitter you Sons can you please
reinstate my account thank you there's a
threat that you'd be worried about yeah
so are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're inundated we are
really working hard for you we're just
asking patients to be patient with us
hey Barbie world you weren't asked to
give evidence to the grand jury I'm the
only one that has Battalion materials
you don't drink never taken drugs you're
stinking Rich should you be concerned
if it's on your mind it's on talk TV
it's about you and your opinions if
you're thinking about it we're talking
about it
it's all about me that's a joke
[Music]
welcome back to uncensored now it is a
question as puzzled scientists for
centuries are we alone on the Third Rock
From the Sun or is there life out there
in the infinite Abyss scientists at
Harvard University say they've maybe one
step closer to that answer claiming to
have recovered material that originated
outside our solar system for the first
time in history the tiny spheres were
discovered at the bottom of the Pacific
Ocean and Professor RV Loeb known as the
world's foremost alien Hunter says they
may even be the debris of a UFO but not
everyone is entirely convinced to find
out more let's talk to the man himself
Professor RV Loeb author of interstellar
the search for extraterrestrial life and
our future beyonder thank you so much
for making time for us and please
explain this to an idiot because you are
when it comes to things like this in the
simplest terms what you found and what
it means
thanks for having me well about a decade
ago U.S government satellites spotted
the Fireball from an object that
collided with Earth roughly half a meter
in size and it moved very fast in fact
faster than 95 percent of the stars in
the vicinity of the Sun and moreover it
was also tougher than all the space
rocks reported by NASA over the past
decade so that raised the possibility
that maybe it's a voyager like meteor an
object that resembles the spacecraft
that we launched and the question is
whether it's technological in origin or
natural so we went to the Pacific Ocean
collected uh droplets that were melted
off the surface of the object and landed
on the ocean floor uh about two
kilometers deep and we brought them back
to Harvard University 700 of them and
studied their composition and amazingly
over the past two months we realize that
they are made of a composition that is
very different from solar system
materials and therefore we conclude that
this object came from outside the solar
system a very different environment and
of course to figure out if it's indeed
technological or natural we need to find
bigger pieces so that will be the
subject of a future Expedition how does
this uh differ from other reports we've
heard of kind of sightings and various
things you know there was this House of
Representatives oversight committee that
we had just a few weeks ago
whistleblower was talking about the US
government covering up Knowledge from
the public about extraterrestrial
particles or objects you know again very
simply explain to us how what you've
discovered is something new
well the difference is that we found the
materials we found the evidence we are
sharing it publicly whereas the
discussion in the Congress was all about
hearsay there was a person who heard
from 40 other people that there are
these programs but he hasn't seen the
materials himself and so we didn't see
the evidence as of yet it's all about
the evidence the work of a scientist is
to collect the evidence analyze the
materials and reach conclusions that are
shared with everyone that's what I'm
trying to do now you have come up
against some disputes within your
scientific Community I'm sure this is a
very pleasant thing to do but I'm gonna
let the audience know Dr Matthew Genji
of Imperial College London basically
saying seafloor is littered with
spherials some natural some artificial
you can find all sorts down there
professor Matthew Garrett University of
Manchester says I really admire RV's
enthusiasm in the search for
extraterrestrial intelligence but I'd be
surprised if this recent effort is going
to produce conclusive evidence why is it
that you're coming up against these
kinds of objections within your
community
well because experts
have their stature based on past
knowledge I'm trying to get new
knowledge that is not in line with their
past knowledge so that makes them a
little upset and they reject it ahead of
time but I have the evidence we did the
scientific analysis it's not a matter of
opinion whatever the instruments show us
we report and that's the way science is
done I'm really surprised that people
have opinions before looking at the data
that is not the way science should be
done and of course the ocean is littered
with sparrows the type of droplets that
we found but we did find droplets that
are common elsewhere outside of the
region where the meteor crashed and in
the meteor side we found an excess of
those droplets of a completely different
nature that's the whole point of our
paper and just finally uh within your
book you talk about this theory of
government should invest two trillion
dollars a year in space exploration I
say opposed to you know spending money
on weapons and blowing each other up on
Earth which would have to sort out first
do you think that you'll ever see that
kind of consensus towards space
exploration
well John Lennon said that imagine all
the people living in peace and I do
believe that the wake-up call from a
neighbor might change our priorities
because first we would realize that we
are not the smartest kid on the Block
and we can learn from others who were
more intelligent because they reached
our doorstep before we reached their
doorstep and so I think there is a lot
to hope for that perhaps everyone on
Earth would realize we are all in the
same boat the Earth sailing through
space and we should work together rather
than fight each other well I've
certainly learned something from
somebody more intelligent this evening
RV lope thanks so much for making time
for us
thanks for having me uncensored next to
shocking footage of the Notting Hill
Carnival has been spread around the
world is it time to ban or move it
that's what some are saying we'll be
debating it next
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
this is talk TV
talk TV's very own Piers Morgan
uncensored is nominated in the brand new
TV interview category at this year's
National Television Awards best TV
interview of course he's up for it it's
probably although exclusive interviews
with the likes of Cristiano Ronaldo
they're trying to force you out yes I
feel betrayed Donald Trump I believe it
was a free and fair election then you're
a fool Kanye West I'm simply going to
challenge you interview adjourned have I
forgotten anyone wake up
I mean he does get some good interviews
it has to be said prime minister Mr
President first lady Stormy Daniels
they've all been fantastic interviews
and if you agree
you can vote for peers go online have
your say nationaltvawards.com but you
can also scan that code and vote for
peers please get behind him and vote we
know we're new we know we're different
the force behind talk deserves to win
keep it award-winning
Piers Morgan uncensored vote for him so
get online and cast your vote for peers
now give the poor guy a chance please I
beg you good luck peers good luck Pez
let it roll
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to uncensored now we did
speak about it briefly on the show last
night but wanted to revisit it today
with a bit more time and some important
voices Notting Hill Carnival debates
about its management and its future they
happen every August when police reports
come out about the number of stabbings
and arrests made this year around 2
million attendees at Notting Hill
Carnival of which there were 308 arrests
more than 50 police officers were
injured and there were some eight
stabbing incidents including two young
men suffering life-threatening injuries
this picture was also on the front page
of the times today
understandably there are concerns but
this year conversations are getting more
heated they're being found by the Flames
of social media noisy influences and I'm
going to put it bluntly it's becoming
about racism because it's an event with
Caribbean roots and holds importance
with the black community joining me to
discuss all of this is founder of the
Kingston Carnival John Azar talk TV
contributor Esther kraku and former met
police chief superintendent Kevin Hurley
Kevin thank you for making time with us
and I understand you you've policed a
few of these carnivals just give us a
sense of what it is like preparing for
one of these events
well it's a
it's an event and too hard really the
first bit of it particularly the
children's Carnival is actually really
quite a pleasant event
um but as the day builds up and
particularly when it moves into night
especially on the Monday night
it is actually quite frightening to be
there particularly if you're a police
officer because it is Extremely Loud you
actually can't physically talk to a
person standing next to you and the
noise from some of the speakers is
actually visceral gets your your insides
vibrating sometimes and from a police
officer point of view and I'll just
describe it as a constable Sergeant
there or inspector who are the ones on
the ground
it's very intimidating because you'll
get groups of black youths if we're
talking about it bouncing into knocking
trying to knock you over
some of the police women being sexually
uh assaulted and so on and you're very
isolated people committed all kinds of
offenses in front of you often and it's
really quite scary so that's kind of
like a policeman's a police officer's
perspective no one in the Police Service
wants to go and work at the carnival
because it's such an unpleasant and on
in the evenings scary experience but the
problem with it is the first day the
children's Carnival and song which is
very good and even on the beginnings on
on the Monday
is is pretty good but what you get then
is gangs of troublemakers going there
doing robberies exploiting really the
absence of any effective policing gang
fights occur and of course what we've
seen is the stabbings
Etc so what are my thoughts on it
um
I think we need to consider what it's
like for the residents who live in that
area
who for the most part have their life
blighted for two days but then hey when
they bought their houses there they knew
the carnival came around every year so
that's part of it probably reflected in
the price
well I kind of think that despite the
best efforts of police and what they do
in terms of
kind of trying to avoid the crashing I
think from a point of view of just
safety and control a large open public
space rather like the Glastonbury events
and so on would probably be better but
then of course you lose some of the
Ambiance of parading around the streets
and so on yeah
from the Met police point of view it's a
massive drain on resources they have to
call on the city of London Police and
some other forces to bring it in and
just to do it as a police officer is a
thoroughly unpleasant experience where
you're subject to a lot of hostility
extreme noise and and quite often
violence and and do hear all of that um
Kevin and appreciate you sharing your
experiences as well uh let's come to the
studio John and talk about this you're
involved with Kingston Carnival which
has associations with Nottingham
Carnival as well
um when you hear a police officer
talking about the experience of the
event like that do you acknowledge that
there are safety concerns that need to
be addressed
I thank you for for having me I I think
it's fair to say that if you pull
together any
big event it doesn't have to be Carnival
it could be England playing uh Germany
if you pull together any big event
depends on who is going to that event
there's always a criminal element in
that audience and so I think let's let's
concentrate on on the festivals that
we're talking about not in carnival
historically was set up because he
wanted to bring black people who settled
in London together because they felt
oppressed and that they needed something
to bring those communities together so
many years later obviously is grown to
become a very big event in in in in in
in in Europe and I think rather than
people like Kevin
continuing to happen about this event
being very violent and you know police
officers have been fearful we ought to
look at the bigger picture
this carnivore brings attention to
London indeed the one we organized in
Kingston even though it's a small event
we bring people from Notting Hill
Carnival the mass bands coming to
Kingston we don't have any criminal
element in Kingston in fact we organize
I would argue that one of the safest
festivals in that part of the world is
the biggest thing which happens and
therefore I think culturally somehow you
feel as if when black people want to do
something which is special for those
communities people
agnosium criticized those events no
matter what it is whereas you know Kevin
compared a carnival to Glastonbury
there's a number of things which happen
in Glastonbury I haven't had anybody
complain to argue that they should shut
down Glastonbury reading festival and
those things and never I think it's it's
quite Rich for people who criticize
Carnival not to prescribe anything
positive about what we ought to be doing
with communities rather than every year
when this thing comes along they talk
about only the violence they don't talk
about the good things that it brings to
the area and how we should be harnessing
what black people have brought as
cultural migrants to this country and
ought to be celebrating that's what we
do in Kingston we show the borough that
this is what we bring and we bring the
residents together to celebrate our
diversity which and in fact this year we
are celebrating well-being and promoting
cultural diversity because
post covered we know that a lot of
people from black and minoritized
communities died and we want to harness
what we've lost and celebrate with
people who really want to learn
something from us culturally and that's
what we're doing and therefore it's not
about stopping anything it's about
promoting and celebrating what we
brought you mentioned the other
festivals there and Kevin brought them
up and Kevin I will come back to you uh
for your reaction to that but Esther
let's talk about this because a lot of
people do make the comparisons not in
carnival versus reading versus
Glastonbury we compared the arrests made
at those uh versus attendance and
obviously arrest get made for all sorts
of reasons while it's all drug related
it's hard to make apples and oranges
comparison but actually not single
Carnival percentage-wise was fewer
arrested exactly and I think that's what
people need to put into perspective look
I understand what you know um the
gentleman was saying about the
difficulties with policing something
like that um with Nottingham Nottingham
Carnival with over 2 million attendees
and you know there will there will be
incidents of of of on civil unrest
that's that's a given and that happens
with even less to me with has like what
200 000 so very you know tiny proportion
of what Notting Hill gets um but the
reality is if you put it in proportion
to the actual number of people that go
to Nottingham Carnival actually 300
arrests is success is a success and we
don't then we don't often you know
celebrate the Metropolitan Police
there's always sort of negative press
around the Metropolitan Police but I
actually think this is one of the things
that we should celebrate them the most
for because they yes it does it is a
huge drain on resources but it's done
well and that's why we have so few
arrests and obviously we can't ignore
the violence but that's almost
inevitable it's just about trying to
police better and trying to give the
police the resources that they feel they
need to do a better and and job that
they feel more comfortable with because
I think that's the issue yeah one thing
we noticed when we were discussing this
in the production team was that a lot of
the criticism this year picks up videos
that are non-violent it's just people
celebrating in the crowd and they're
being circulated wide on social media
and by people in the US casting moral
judgment on the event itself do you
think people people grinding people
grinding people twerking people grinding
listen they went for the cheeks and they
got some cheeks and if you don't like it
don't go uh there is no obligation for
you to receive some of the Cheeks from
the cheek Gods as we are seeing right
now
but John do you do you think that people
are using the discussion about safety
which is a discussion that needs to be
had about the carnival but they're using
that to basically cast judgment
well I I think you can't you can't
ignore the subliminal racism which is
taking place in here you know we we need
to call this out I mean I think without
mentioning you know names you know Susan
Hall who is the prospective uh PP uh
mayor mayor candidate for London it says
some really really Dreadful things about
black people and crime she says some
really terrible things about Kingston uh
Nottingham Carnival
and I think
we need to ensure that when people talk
about nothing in canvas Esther is saying
we promote the positives which are
taking place rather than just
concentrating I don't hear a lot of
people any year and I've been going to
not hear Carnival for years I'm working
with the the some of the mass months for
years I don't hear anybody coming out
one year and saying well actually this
was a really successful cultural event
and that we ought to con continue to
celebrate most of the people that
criticize Nottingham Carnival I must
point out haven't actually don't go yeah
and every year I notice there are
stories like this and look I'm not
saying it's not important to highlight
the difficulty that the police has with
controlling the public and and tackling
anti-social behavior of course we should
talk about it but we should talk about
how to improve that how to make their
jobs easier not to just paint it as a
suspect of violence because actually
statistically it's a pretty safe event
that's why two million people go that's
why it's the largest street festival in
Europe
um so I think it's important to just
have some perspective there Let's cross
back together and when I do Kevin I'm
getting Susan Hall as uh John brought up
her remarks about people in the black
community saying there's a problem with
crime and actually since softened Her
starts mayoral candidate of course
saying it's very upsetting I'm afraid
we'd have this every single year I would
say move the carnival it's where it can
be policed much better which is the same
suggestion um that you have you've been
listening to Esther and John in the
studio do you have any final remarks
you'd like to make about the way they
perceive the event versus you as a
policeman
well I think I think first points I'd
make is that John as I was quite right
that I haven't police football grounds
and dealt with hooliganism that is
extremely frightening I think the thing
I'm trying to make about Carnival again
it's it's an event of two parts it's
great it's fine I would have no
difficulty going myself on the first day
as who I am now you know an old boy
but I would not be hanging around on the
Monday evening as Darkness Falls because
there is a palpable change in atmosphere
and the point I make is it's not really
whether or not it should move there or
it should go to Hyde Park or wherever is
that to do it as a police officer
is very frightening because of the fact
you face such hostility when you're
moving around the crowd at that event
and it's a result of what I would what I
as we as we talked about I would call
the batari box of the policing
experience in London indeeding with
young black people and young black
people being engaged with police it's
almost like a vicious circle how both
groups tend to react to each other young
police officers and young black people
and it kind of feeds itself in very
negative terms how you break that if you
like psychological situation I don't
know but it's one of the reasons why the
carnival is very unpleasant to police as
a police officer yeah it's a cultural
event yeah it is a cultural event we
have just run out of time but
interesting points that thank all three
of you for that
uncensored next tonight England Captain
Harry Kane embracing German culture by
wearing Lederhosen but isn't that
cultural appropriation we'll be talking
about it next
[Music]
foreign
Morgan uncensored in New York City King
peers and King Q I think it's only one
for one king
he's mopped your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail start working just because
their skin folk don't mean they're
kinfolks you believe you can win this
war it's making me cry again they're
trying to force you out yes I feel
betrayed keep it award-winning
Lucy Lefty will die behind bars and a
senior Doctor Who first raised concerns
about that he wants NHS managers to be
regulated we needed answers a lot sooner
this is what seven years down the line I
mean it's completely ludicrous we need
accountability we need performance in
all walks of life if this nurse had
misgendered somebody on a ward she'd
have been out the door when they first
got together there were press stories
way TK team that would make her a better
princess of wealth Elaine Maxwell agreed
to be interviewed for the very first
time I obviously wish I'd never met him
Donald Trump has just said he expects to
be arrested at 7 30 P.M
the conservative party can certainly win
the next election yes
did he say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
[Music]
if we stop producing oil the knock-on
effect is far larger than just CO2 I
nearly have empathy when I'm speaking to
them I know no you're probably going to
vote me off
some of them they're easily LED
you can kiss my American ass thank you
very much
very nice of you
Twitter you Sons can you please
reinstate my account thank you that's a
threat that you'd be worried about so
are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed or inundated we are really
working hard for you we're just asking
patients to be patient with us
when I'm in Barbie world you weren't
asked to give evidence to the grand jury
I'm the only one that has been telling
the trails you don't drink never taken
drunk you're stinking Rich should you be
concerned
if it's on your mind it's on talk TV
it's about you and your opinions if
you're thinking about it we're talking
about it
it's all about me that's a joke
[Music]
coming up on the talk Prince Harry
appears to hit out at the royal family
saying he didn't get support when he
returned from Afghanistan and cowardly
criminals like Lucy letby will be forced
to attend their sentencing under new
rules announced by the Prime Minister
and Church of England priests believe
Britain can no longer be described as a
Christian country that's all coming up
at nine o'clock
[Music]
welcome back to Onsen so join now by our
Wednesday evening pack socialist author
Grace Blakely and talktv contributor
Esther Krakow remains with us in the
studio
thanks both so much and let's pick up
that story that the talk just said
they're going to cover tonight give our
own Slants on it before they do but this
idea of criminals being forced to face
their victims in court this is obviously
sparked by the Lucy letby case soon act
has taken it on as a cause basically uh
let's listen actually to a clip from him
people have committed awful crimes
somehow are able to take the coward's
way out and not appear in court for
their sentencing and to hear the impact
that their crimes have had on the
victims families I don't think that's
right there shouldn't be an easy way out
and that's why we're going to change the
law so that courts can compel these
offenders to be present for their
sentencing and to hear the impact that
their actions have had no I don't think
there's going to be many people at home
that disagree with that I suppose it
does intersect with a human rights piece
at some point I'm certainly not
knowledgeable enough about the law to
say that as such but Grace I mean I
think he's kind of he's grasping at
straws a bit isn't he he's like like
launched on this case in particular
which obviously everyone is reacting to
rightly as saying this is utterly
horrific and trying to say we will use
this as a launch pad to kind of be much
more tough on crime have harsher
sentences for these types of crimes
compel people to um to appear in court
and you know that might all be all very
well and good but ultimately this
government has been in power for a while
the conservative party has been in power
for a very very long time he's had
plenty of time to do this the only
reason he's suddenly grasping at all of
this stuff now is to appear tough on
crime in the run-up to an election
actually you know if he really wanted to
do something about the Parlor state of
our Criminal Justice System he would
invest something in it we've had you
know legal age lawyers were on strike
last year because the backlog of caters
in the criminal justice system is just
appalling because there's not enough
money going into it yeah so it just
seems like it's just striking as well to
be cynical about it Esther is a
convenient political move well the thing
is he's ordered guidance into how to
make it happen so he's talking about
changing the law actually he's ordered
guidance to see
um whether it would be possible to um
to enforce reasonable uh Force I guess
to actually Force these these criminals
to to go into court and to face their
sentencing um but again there will be
human rights you know implications there
can you physically drag them by their
hair you know is that even possible and
also for the people that commit these
heinous crimes they will likely be
sentenced to a whole life order so you
can't actually you know sentence them to
give them a worse or a more severe
sentence because that's the maximum
penalty you can get in the UK and it's
not like so what what what what's left
to lose
someone like that is is presumably a
psychopath like they're not going to
admit you know fault or feel any guilt
what if she misbehaves in the court what
if she flips the the families of the
bird right what if she she starts
shouting what if she continues to defend
the memory of the victims I mean they're
real implications to doing this because
you don't actually know how the person
that you've just dragged into court is
going to behave and whether it's in an
undignified manner that's actually going
to prolong the victim's family's torment
so I actually don't think this is a very
I mean look the the the the incentive in
our league in our political system to to
constantly jump on these Trends and to
jump on what we think the public will
appreciate us for is actually I think it
doesn't help or ameliorate the public
discourse on things that really matter
well your point about setting you know
I've heard people say today you know
people just get dragged into court to
hear they've got a 12 month suspended
you know it's look let's let's move on
and talk about later hosts and shower
it's what we price people in the mood
the real news of the day I do want to do
the warning do you want to do this
Chester wants to give you all a trigger
warning because this is Harry Kane in
lederhosen
have we got pictures of uh we've got
some pictures of Harry Kane here and
there he is walking through uh he's of
course been signed over to Bayern Munich
unacceptable here he is posing for some
promotional photos uh Lighthouse and of
course the National Dress of Germany
he's also wearing one of their their
jackets as well and I'm going to say
it's Bayern Munich's official website
builds this as the moment
which means the moment you've all been
waiting for they are riding high off
this this is the England Captain eating
white sausage drinking wheat beer and
wearing later hose and are you shocked
and appalled Grace there obviously
enjoying this
I love a man in shorts and I think he
looks great I know that you're going to
disagree with me about that I like about
it all depends on the shorts it depends
on the man you know because the thing is
when I saw the picture in the newspaper
I was like I can see the outline of his
watch I don't want to see the outline of
Harry Kane's crotch before I've had
breakfast so I was I was a bit
um
my grandmother was Austrian
um let's see if this changes your mind
somebody else in lederhosen
fears Morgan dancing through the fields
oh that is that is that is that deserves
the trigger warning I think that we all
I'm doubling down um look at the thighs
on that one my God
I don't think we're in uh deep concern
of Piers Morgan suddenly playing for
Bayern Munich but we do know what he
looks like in lederhosen now we're gonna
be able to have conversations like this
when he comes back I know because I just
gonna shut it down he's like are you all
right we've got one more day for the
production team to mock him up in
various outfits so for us all to mock
him here in the studio his own very own
show
um and then he's gonna come back so
let's make the most of it while we can
but you don't have any concerns about
our England Captain playing in Germany
no I mean you know
like maybe he'll pick up some skills
maybe we will win something maybe he has
something to bring us I block I feel uh
the camera operators here in the studio
who are all male and bristling with
comments
about the sport that is it from us
whatever you're up to tonight make sure
it's uncensored good night
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you